me about these WhatsApp messages that
we're seeing in the Daily Telegraph
suggestions that sir Gavin Williamston
who I know that you have worked with
when you at the ministry of Defense
saying that teachers didn't want to work
during the pandemic and what was
actually happening at the top of
government at the time these are
absolutely important questions which is
why it's so critical that we have a
proper inquiry what we've seen now in
the last few days is a Daily Telegraph
get an immense amount of data my concern
is that we're going to get this drip
feed as we do when this data sort of
comes out there are people wanting to
provide their angle of their story I do
hope that the inquiry is able to wrap up
and provide its conclusions soon because
it's so important that we learn lessons
from this there could easily be another
pandemic in the future mistakes were
made there was no rule book there was no
blueprint for us to follow in in the
past as to how we respond to this virus
but ultimately challenges were made and
I think accepting some mistakes were
made as well the idea that we sort of
picked through individual things I can't
really comment because I don't know the
details but I am more generally is the
fact that without leaving the detail
aside what does it say about a former
Health secretary who gives up a hundred
thousand WhatsApp private messages many
of them one to one end-to-end encrypted
I'm sure there's a data protection
issues there
um to a journalist who he knows is a
covered lockdown denier what does that
say about somebody at the top of
government
I I the way you articulate the question
I think speaks volumes it's not in my
character to you know want to start
making personal comments like that Matt
Hancock has chosen his new path of where
he wants to go and how he wants to do it
I I just hope the inquiry getting back
to politics and the very important
questions that many many uh people
across the country including your
viewers will want to know you know what
happened what happened within the Care
Homes the decisions surrounding those
with loved ones that affected them
that's the details we want we don't know
the exact truth because this is one side
of the story and another all very very
serious all the more important that the
inquiry is made it could be with the
Care Homes just to focus on that for a
second that perhaps the inquiry could do
a limited study on that and produce that
much much earlier I'm worried with these
inquiries that they drag on sometimes
for years and that will be I think you
know it's unhelpful we need to get the
results now provide and I think people
want answers as soon as possible my
questions so I'll let you off on that
one but I suppose I'll ask it in a
different way which is would you release
all your WhatsApp messages no I wouldn't
I think there's I mean I think that was
done for personal gain and I'm sorry
about that you know a bigger picture
look what has happened this last sweet
with our conservative party for the
first time we've Illustrated some
statecraft that I'm not seen for quite
some time that's what the electorate
wants to see Richie sunac managed to
land that deal which showed what happens
when you have leadership determination
Vision Focus bridge building rather than
the bombastic
partisan aggression that we've had in
the past we're starting to regroup you
saw that in the chamber yesterday in
prime minister's questions that's what
we should be illustrating a new culture
of wanting to do what's best for the
nation so all these stories about what's
happened in the past now you know I
think there are distractions to where we
want to go we have a possibility of
winning the next general election and we
need greater discipline and focus that's
what the nation wants to see yeah um
apparently he did it to um because she
was Ghost writing his book A book that
sold 4 000 copies is that right I didn't
know that yeah I put a smile on your
face thanks for joining us as always
thanks very much